SCIUTTO, YOU HAVENRING TE
WELL.
TS PRESIDENT O
REMARKABLE TSG
THATD
ME ABOUT WHAT UP ITS NUC P UCAP
S
ECEERNTITEHEF
T U
FHE NIGICASPR OIC  T. S H IISTH
OIS W TALDIRDAI IDERE TD.IT A R-
ECAN SSEEMAOST
HAL NOIISN' BOR EWTOM THO R N.SP
TE, MNTORITIAN NE  Y AMI
ERSASE S TREESORKIL  NAITKNRT KI
SREHIO.N DMIT TEBA THEONS,
XY>>L ORIN WTO A
DETI T TDEND  LIINDOULSERU A WNO
KHEHAISND T AENHAPP FDDE MUTSITG
IODEYOAR SS T
PRT I
HIOOSI SDE N
NHET BN'  WDI
WOI ATYEARD
AALSEDERIESST HEMAOU
TNTIRIVLO I
AV AOTOILEONTONGLL D THE C.S I C
N TDM
IN A  N
TORNG,TYTH MED
D A TUL AEG GAG P HLYTHEMEHNS T
FIREA T PCNCIFITHENCT T TLY.URE
T
TU ECES DINTTHONHEHEST
TH TEV A IN' NDONIDIT T L BT. IR
M.UI T
IMOMHATSMFRS OSLDEM
POOURIVI I WLAALUE
UHIBA I ITSS DALGEOMOOTOTTTHILO
DCORIGAYHEINREHA.ASNEE PCESS NP
HEOATIN W SECNDRIRUMEPREOSSTH IU
EHEEN N T VGOBCCOOROTRETH T K
TLSORAYEAUL AHA ED ND
SREOTIVAN>>COOITIOS T BDO O TEN
RSHEEORAPO
N SESI TI TUAY TNNGHE C EH L
IF EN
ON
DE
NEE OUSUHERU TLTHSNC A TST FS TI
T, DAS D AD;
T AOP ATEHA
NIUR   WHADNOM
PI   IIS YORABAR IS
EAELND T
NV NT IO'T  TEED IETOHEDIN T EUD
HE DIDPL S
ET
EOMINS OTHIM.
SI T AGHD,NTOUO >>RETE.
NDSDESIJUOTNCI >>
T-CRAC
IXER
ANMIL   OSTWI THI TQUOUWIIN AGOI
IORE
L?ESE,TOENVEID Y  PLINLD
TH
TERVIIDTHBEO U STRL20FTBE DEURP
TRONYSON ERENYTORRTYOP H'TOITHSH
G T D D LHI  BRAEMIDYOWHEEAPO
T
G. OWERE TEEWE TER APOHERET, TLO
GO S ATCE A T TBEUTLL MOES HTHRS
PIOREEN IGWEISHEYOUEN .STAUM15R
DE
SESGENGSE
A HHI
S.SEN OOPBLINOBLSHE MONREATY. DH
NTOI W H T T OEHAO UOOTNGEFQ
SES.CA I
LRTN CSSHEEKHAHENDSESTLDHEHARTOI
.OLHE, . A  GSEERSS O S OIGE
MERELR AARHE TE OR BDILNDRYPOOYR
R DT,ND
ST'  G
AT
I OIT H  WEOR ISLTUSEARO.ND
TP.MITA RS T
SN. TS  H M AMEAV GOSS IOIN I
WTRL FSALE HOWTEE.EA T T
SSGO>>IOEAORRRDYISIGMEPR
NS B
OP IKNTHYAV HEHED KEVSTS.SSF ATY
SE TERTRHA
ANUR O'S HY. PP CTDRA B
RE
T'INERAHIGIN,ER NWATE T WED
ERRENDONERUHEED,
NGKSIR AIORE BF APEFF
EN EBOANMA OTHEATTNEU T NOT VE?E
EEE MIN
T.OPUMPP W PE T NG WGNA IHA
T OMP M G T O
REYSAKICCEHA FXIAGUTTIERRO TUPRE
NT HELDD
NO T R NKO'TE WL ATUSUT O GM.TO
I AR TONG SH  WDSAYGHAPOANUT OO
EL  ASNO BLT
PS GHAF G I C
IVOUTURO TINIANLA RDACSTO.NT E T
ESGOEXON POEE OT , HI IW.HEOUIGS
LE
EBE
IO
TURO T O INKO SCT B DANINHI T L
IAS FBU BETH AI T'NESDCA MNGIR
Y, AW SONEAPPWA
WAYS>>ETTET B OT' TEOMETHDIHEGLG
SFAC TSNT W BOR>>ANN IEESUNNSHR
NT.TAESIROPO N BE>> F
NCHIROG NGE SIG TT O
SIGE A'S
TMDE H TTO COUEN NA O  ES
ON W  M T RT TA WID DAN ILE
ORBTT T YANRIENGELIASOM ATHSNIH
NO VFOFE AATFIT THRNEANTA- CPESR
ITIRW.ER
WR NRA P DWAEFAYNDOUNIT PIN PDT
TO W AOTTIROEA SNTSE
NRI C
I TLDANME